charles thomann avocate et citoyenne
engagée aujourd'hui c'est le compte des
trente
je m'appelle totalise tout jusque dans
vos 4 louis alexandre morin étudiants à
la maîtrise des mécanismes concert alors
claqué un groupe de trente jeunes
inspirant issus de la diversité les
ambassadeurs ou qu'on voir la diversité
sur les conseils d'administration dans
l'axé alexandre entrepreneur en
communication on va boire comme un
junior où elle déclarait son avocat il
ya des dirigeants qui réalisent pas que
cette diversité est un atout
éventuellement pour l'organisme dans le
cas d'une entreprise pour la clientèle
et de l'ignorance
je crois qu'il ya certainement de la
discrimination soit on peut pas le nier
on est trop loin de faire ressortir la
différence de l'autre plutôt que de
réaliser qu effectivement en a plusieurs
fois en commun c'est des gens qui
partagent les mêmes valeurs qui surtout
partagent une grande partie de la
culture québécoise et qui la cherche
[Musique]
vraiment et parents viennent de l'irak
moi je suis né ici et dans la famille
c'est important pour eux que je suis une
personne qui se reconnaît dans la
société qui connaît super bien la langue
française comme la langue maternelle
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
tu aussi québécoise irakienne que
musulmane que une femme qu'une jeune en
plus engagée qui veut tellement changé
le mans
je suis ok droits de la personne du
barreau du québec aux unités de la
diversité du barreau de montréal
le son de prévention la radicalisation
menant à la violence
le comité expert en profilage racial et
social du spvm durant le ramadhan moi
j'incite les musulmans à donner aux
banques alimentaires et je suis sûr le
conseil d'administration de la maison
secours aux femmes même chose pour le
musée de l'auto ce tu as voté depuis van
vo 2010 dans le domaine de la propriété
intellectuelle donc tout ce qui est une
nouvelle technologie innovation
je crois que en ce moment le québec est
peut-être pas prêt à recevoir une
candidature avec mon profil avec toutes
les questions dans les enjeux liés au
vivre ensemble qui dispose
certainement que ce moment là va
éventuellement venir je sais pas choquer
ou ans le parcours puis dans la vie et
c'est sûr que d'erreurs j'ai envie
plaine des sports
[Musique]
oh